I grew up a very dorky weird-looking kid
in suburban Seattle and to make matters
worse another way in which I didn't fit
in was my parents were behind
members of the Baha'i faith and I grew
up a member of the Baha'i faith and one
of the great things about that was that
I had a very Catholic from the original
use of the word Catholic view of
religions we we soaked in all kinds of
different beliefs
Java's witnesses would knock on the door
we would invite them in and discuss the
Bible with them we would have Buddhist
monks traveling through town stay with
us we had books on Sufism and Sikhism
and I knew about all of these things and
I was raised to think about philosophy
and religious thought and the soul and
the spirit of humankind in a different
way also really socially progressive
teachings of the Baha'i faith the
Equality of men and women the
elimination of racial prejudice the
Equality of science and religion so it
was a big cauldron of big ideas in in my
household and we were a weird and
unhappy family but nonetheless that was
a really positive thing that came out of
it then when I I moved to New York in my
20s I I really abandon all that and so
many people do that grow up in religious
households they just abandon the way of
their parents I I decided there there
couldn't be a god there was so much
suffering in the world even perpetrated
so much evil I wanted to go my own way
and take my own journey and what I did
is I became an artist and I just focused
on being an actor and all of my
attention just went to and my my kind of
my fervor went to theater and acting and
I really thought you know with my
friends that went to school down at NYU
we would do little basement productions
of had a gobbler or whatever and we
really thought we could change the world
if we did the right piece of theater in
the right way with the right audience we
could touch people's hearts and we could
just blow their minds and just open
things up come
and I also focused on my career as an
actor a great deal and I became very me
focused and me centered just myself in
my career and what next and how do I get
a better agent and how do I get into TV
and movies and and then I you know I I
felt a yearning I came to a crossroads I
hit bottom in a way I was really unhappy
and realized that I just wanted
something more about from the experience
of being alive I was like I was doing
great plays it wasn't changing the world
I was getting good agents and doing film
and TV and I wasn't happier I was like
wow there's there's an unease inside of
me and that led me back on my kind of
more spiritual path to the Baha'i faith
in a new and fresh way in a more
realized way and I came to also
understand at that point that there was
no difference between being devout and
being an artist there's no difference
between creativity and spirituality and
philosophy and that's what soul pancake
the book and soul pancake calm are about
is it's all about human expression and
it's all about seeking to transcend it's
about that yearning and whether it's
through science or through art through
service through worship it's the human
experience of longing to connect with
people to connect with the energy and
throughout creation and we
compartmentalize all of these things and
I realize oh it's all the same thing
I played Dwight that's just as much me
being a service and and of and
worshiping as if I'm on my knees in some
temple somewhere or bowing my head in
prayer to God in some way it's really
all just the same thing
I sleep like a log I always have I just
I hit the pillow and it's like um what
keeps my wife up at night is my
horriffic snoring which I gotta get
taken care of and I need to get those
nose strips